on a worcestershire farm
they harvest spring onions all day
in all weathers
this is hard graft paid by the bunch
and the workers here have come from all
over the world
but since brexit every one of them needs
a special visa
and this year workers have been in short
supply with claims of visa delays and
the war in ukraine leaving hundreds of
thousands of bunches in the ground
finding people now is becoming
increasingly difficult
at the beginning of may we were 40 short
of the people we should have here they
were all recruited they just hadn't got
the visas process
we lost three quarters of a million
bunches of spring onions with a value of
about a hundred thousand so overall
shortage labor cost us a quarter million
pounds in may
and it's not just onions this is what
asparagus looks like when you stop
picking it
in may they had to flatten the spears to
buy time as they waited for workers
and when they did arrive they weren't
enough they should have been harvesting
this asparagus until the third week of
june but the labor shortage meant they
couldn't keep up with growth and they
had to stop at the start of may letting
these plants grow to fern and leaving 45
000 kilos of asparagus worth 150 000
pounds in the ground
last year the government granted 30 000
seasonal work of visas of these nineteen
thousand six hundred and fourteen more
than sixty percent went to ukrainians
this year an extra ten thousand visas
have been granted taking the total to
forty thousand but the national farmers
union estimates seventy five thousand
are needed to meet demand
the government plans to end the scheme
altogether in 2024 but the conservative
chairman of the environment food and
rural affairs committee said that could
stop investment
it wants to be a permanent scheme if
you're planting a vineyard or building a
pack house you need to be sure that you
can have labour to come and do that work
in the into the future
this migration expert says cutting labor
may change what british farmers grow
you could imagine a scenario where the
scheme tapers down and
agriculture in the uk particularly
labor-intensive bits of the agricultural
industry like soft fruit
just become smaller
the government says it wants farmers to
produce more but british agriculture
can't grow if the labor force shrinks
paul kelso sky news in worcestershire